Ruth Zuniga wants justice that's been a
long time coming like 300,000 other
women in Peru she was a victim of forced
sterilization in the nineties the then
President of Peru Alberto Fujimori
initiated a program to combat poverty
and encourage birth control the
sterilizations were framed as voluntary
but the women forced to have them say
they were anything but ruth is trying to
get other victims to break their silence
and demand compensation can she
convinced these women to stand up for
their rights
mommy Taiwan China awesome a mutator
Scalia today Ruth is visiting a village
in Peru's Cusco region she's trying to
identify and register women who were
forcibly sterilized in a government
program that lasted for two decades
you've got to hand in a report you've
got to tell us what they did to you I've
done that myself we have to stick
together
women who register will get financial
compensation and help with physical and
psychological problems it's humiliating
it's nothing to be ashamed of we've got
to stay strong sterilization changed
everything
I can't work as hard in the fields as
they used to because of the pain my
husband doesn't understand he thinks I'm
lazy
most of the sterilizations were carried
out in rural areas in poor indigenous
communities many of them could neither
read nor write they had no idea what was
going to happen when they arrived at the
doctor's office that's why many of the
victims are reluctant to register so far
500 women in the Cusco region have
signed up and today Ruth manages to
convince a few more to do so
Mondays already full so sign up for
Tuesday I'll be there the women have to
travel to the regional capital cuzco to
register ruth will go with them to give
them support but it's an election year
and that complicates the situation the
leading candidate for president is the
daughter of former president Alberto
Fujimori who's serving a 25 year prison
sentence for crimes including corruption
the forced sterilization program began
during his administration Ruth wants to
make sure that the women do actually
join the program they're worried some
think the government is spying on them
they're afraid that if they register
they'll get into trouble
Ruth and her husband farmer plot of land
near the village of limbo Tambo about 60
kilometers west of Cusco
we've run out of beans so we'll just
have to do without I'll throw in some
herbs I'm going down to the village
I'll see whether anyone has a job for me
today feed first and bring some water
back with you
Ruth receives no financial compensation
for her work she says she's simply
trying to win respect for the
sterilization victims in the old days a
new wife had to peel potatoes in front
of her mother-in-law you started out
with really small potatoes so you could
prove that you could peel them once you
did you were accepted as a woman thank
God it's not like that anymore
in a manual it was in 1999 February the
10th a nurse asked Ruth to bring her
youngest child to the Medical Center for
a free examination something didn't seem
right so I my husband and my child tried
to get out of there the door was locked
I tried to make it look like I was going
to the restroom but the door wouldn't
open
I could hear women screaming in rooms
nearby I was really scared
they took off my clothes put me in a
green smock and lifted me onto a bed I
asked the nurse why they were doing this
to me they told me they wanted to
examine my child not me they tricked me
she said you've already got four kids
how many more do you want
it's just a small incision it's for your
own good they cut me open
there was a lot of blood the surgeon
said hold her down the nurses grabbed my
arms and head and they tied my feet and
hands to the bed they kept holding my
head down I flashed around I don't know
how it happened but I managed to pull
off the doctors surgical mask
Vega chuckle me man sick Paulo Brazil
amis action / SMS me no magic words no
play staccato through la máscara I saw
right away it was Washington Ortiz many
of the local women say that it was Ortiz
who sterilized them without their
consent
there's been no official investigation
of these cases Ortiz has made no public
comment on them Ruth's husband was not
able to defend or protect his wife at
the time we had no idea what the doctors
were going to do to her how did they
come up with this idea we didn't even
know what sterilization was I didn't
know and neither did my wife we didn't
have a clue so did you sign anything
absolutely not this is the medical
center in the town of anta many of the
local women were sterilized here when
the center first opened president
fujimori himself took part in the
dedication ceremony Washington Ortiz who
carried out so many of the sterilization
procedures still works here he refuses
to appear before our camera and pretends
he's not there many women are afraid of
being treated at the center we finally
found a doctor who was willing to
discuss the sterilization program dr.
Raul Salas carry on is the chairman of
the Regional Medical Council at that
time there were guidelines on how many
women should be sterilized every month
and every year nationwide the numbers
were set by the federal government if a
doctor didn't meet the quota he'd be
moved to another job former president
fujimori denies he knew anything about
the sterilization program his daughter
the presidential candidate puts the
responsibility squarely on the
individual doctors who were involved
now Ruth is on her way to cruise pitar
another village near Cusco lots of
people have come here today to see a
bullfight
perhaps Ruth will be able to sign up
some more women for the compensation
program she meets one of her fellow
volunteers how many women still haven't
signed up 45 I've been talking to some
of them about it Ruth wants to meet as
many of these women as she can who has
signed up a lot of us can't remember
when the procedure took place and some
of the women can't read or write how old
were you at the time and how old are you
now try to remember it's important and
don't forget to bring some official ID
but Ruth knows from experience that not
many of these women will actually
register for the program
on the weekend Ruth's family gathers at
her home her four children now live in
cusco but they visit their parents often
Ruth and Eduardo couldn't imagine a life
without their children Ruth doesn't want
her daughter's to experience what she
went through her goal is to convince the
sterilization victims to break their
silence and get the help they need
you